what we have now among the contemporary
left is simply relativism so they
tolerate things because they think they
are equally valid hey I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Reuben report real quick
everyone don't forget to click that
subscribe button and make sure
notifications are turned on so that you
actually get our videos
okay then joining me today is a British
columnist and the editor of spiked
online and a former Reuben report guest
who we decided to welcome back
Brendan O'Neill welcome back to the
Reuben hey Dave how's again it is going
well I'm glad to have you back it was
about two years ago that we sat down for
the first time and I kind of think that
your political philosophy is pretty much
in line with mine but yeah over the pond
so we're dealing with different
different issues but before we get into
any of that this shirt no one has wore
flowers show believe it's so hot in LA I
get as a as a as a Britain of Irish
descent yes he is just unmanageable so I
had to put on the lightest flower yes
thing that I could find
all right well hence the shirt let's get
into some flowery pollen and so just
quickly for those that don't know who
you are at all we did about an hour and
a half talk already so they can check
out that video will link to it below but
let's just do like a little 4 or 5
minute kind of recap of who you are who
spiked is and and sort of just your
general political philosophy yes so I am
I call myself a left-wing libertarian I
mean it's not the most accurate term it
has very various failings but I think
it's probably the best fit for me
watching we're really probably antennas
going up what are you left-wing yeah
exactly so a lot of people think it's a
contradiction in terms right because the
left has become so incredibly
authoritarian so since Laureus so
divisive so difficult to deal with you
know there are so many problems with a
contemporary left that if you compare if
you have the word left in the same
sentence as the word liberal or
libertarian or freedom people think
that's a contradiction in terms so I
completely understand that but I see
myself as coming from a tradition where
leftist people were in favor of freedom
they were in favor of freedom of speech
they're in favor of counter cultural
experimentation they were in favor of
allowing people to make jokes to write
books to create art however offensive it
may have been so there is a left
tradition which is which does value
freedom which does value Liberty which
does value choice and I see myself as
coming from that tradition unfortunately
that tradition is fading away so people
like me seem quite eccentric but I still
think it's worth holding on to
yes I hear your brother in that that
Poole myself do you find that sort of
staying in that position and saying a
left libertarian to try to say fix it
from the inside as opposed to maybe
working with people that you might not
have worked with before and I think this
will be particularly apropos when we
talk about brexit
I found that working with people on the
right is much more fruitful leas yes but
I respect the people that are still
trying to fix it from the inside I don't
see it happening especially in the
context of American politics it seems to
be getting worse and worse but when you
say left flew retired is that because
you're still trying to kind of fix sort
of what's going on with leftism from
from inside the machine no I don't think
leftism is fixable
I mean I I spend my whole life in a
state of kind of just apoplectic fury
with the left I'm so disappointed with
what has become of the left I cannot
believe that a movement that started out
with the values of universalism has
become this identitarian divisive a
hyper racialist
outfit which is constantly obsessing
over whether you're white or black or
and defining everyone by the biological
boxes that they spend so long trying to
escape from I can't believe that a left
which was traditionally Pro economic
growth Pro Progress wanted to
industrialize the entire third world has
become this kind of environmentalist
save the planet recycle your rubbish
kind of middle class environmentalist
movement so I I spend all my time it's
just feeling so disappointed with what
the left has become and I've reached the
conclusion that I don't think it can be
saved
but I but having said that I do think
and I do work with people on the right
I think alliances across left-right you
know from conservative to radical
whatever it might be I think alliances
are the key feature of contemporary
politics and I think the great dividing
line now is no longer left versus right
no longer a capitalist versus communist
the really important dividing line is
now between do you believe in freedom do
you trust ordinary people to decide for
themselves how they should live or do
you not believe in freedom are you an
authoritarian do you think people need
to be controlled and cajoled and told
what to think I think that's the key
dividing line and I'm willing to work
with and align with anyone who is on the
side of saying we trust people to make
up their own minds and to decide for
themselves how they should live their
lives so by the time we post this video
because everyone knows I'm going off the
grid I will have just handed in my
manuscript for my book and one of the
things that I'm talking about in there
is that perhaps there is a flaw within
that tradition that you're talking about
that I love so much that perhaps within
liberalism itself and the nature of
Tolerance itself and and a removal of
some of the sort of religious
underpinnings that came before the
Enlightenment that there is a something
broken within liberalism it is something
that I don't want to really think about
or even to have to analyze because
that's a scary thought for you know
senator people to have to think about
that this is of course what Sam Harris
and Jordan Peterson had been debating a
lot for the last year and a half and
many others a Ben Shapiro wrote a book
about it do you think there is something
to that I do think there's something to
that I do think there's a god-shaped
hole in contemporary society lots of
people have written about the god-shaped
hole and how you fill it and it's very
difficult to fill it and and nothing
particularly convincing has filled it
thus far but I'm an atheist I don't
believe in God I it's a very tough one
but I know I was brought up a Catholic
so I was brought up very religious I was
an altar boy until I was 16 years old
and I know I've never been anti
religious in the way that some of the
new atheists are I
always understood religion can play an
incredibly important role in people's
lives in terms of providing a framework
providing a moral framework providing
community connections I think it plays
an incredibly important role so I've
never had this kind of anti religious
sometimes quite snobby paternalistic
approach to people who believe in God
but at the same time I think where the
Enlightenment has gone wrong where
Enlightenment values have gone wrong is
not necessarily because the
Enlightenment kind of pushed God aside
and said you know Humanity is the center
and we should we should organize elves
or organize ourselves around the hue
humanist ideal I don't think that's the
problem with enlightenment ideals I
think the the key problem is that the
the Enlightenment ideal of tolerance
which is so important that you tolerate
people even if you disagree with them
you tolerate people even if you think
their values are backward you you value
freedom so much that you're willing to
tolerate people who wear the burqa or
who say outrageous things or who say
racist things because you think freedom
is the core overarching value of cutoff
society I think the problem is that
tolerance has transmogrified into
relativism and so if you look back at
the Enlightenment value of tolerance it
wasn't only saying you have to tolerate
everything and put up with it it was
saying you should tolerate everything in
the name of freedom but at the same time
you are allowed to criticize these
things right so it was I was born as a
two-way street yeah in a weird way now
it's become a one-way absolutely right
so it was a two-way street in the sense
that you would tolerate even backward
beliefs and stupid beliefs and wrong
beliefs you would tolerate them but you
would push back against them you would
say that's wrong that's inferior right
no one uses the word inferior anymore
that that's a bad way to live what we
have now
among the contemporary left is simply
relativism so they tolerate things
because they think they are equally
valid so so is that though because of
the guard shaped all do you do you make
that direct connection because this is
again I come from a secular place on it
yet I find there's almost no way
I know many atheists that are the most
moral good yes generous people at that
micro level at the individual level or
small group level let's say but I'm
finding especially at a time going
against this radical leftist
authoritarian monster that that's why
liberalism is sputtering right now
because it has that that tolerance peace
that's now being used against it yes III
think that's a key problem of our times
I would argue and I say this as a
secularist and an atheist I would argue
that you don't need God in order to be
moral absolutely that you need something
and that's the key issue and what I
think has happened in in recent decades
is that the shift from a God arranged
society to something else has given rise
to this sense of relativism this sense
that everything is equally valid so in
the UK for example Boris Johnson who's
currently running to be leader of the
Tory Party and the next prime minister
he got into a huge amount of trouble for
criticizing the burka he said that women
who wear the burka look like bank
robbers they look like letterboxes they
look crazy I wish they wouldn't wear
this garment and and it causes huge
enormous fuss and people said he should
apologize and retract and these kind of
this furious woke Lobby were saying he
was Islamophobic and all these other
things accusations that they throw at
you what they overlooked is that in the
same article where he made these
ridiculing points he also said we have
to defend the right of women to wear
whatever they want to wear so I actually
thought that he actually summed up the
traditional view of Tolerance which is
that we tolerate people who wear the
burka even if we think it's a stupid
thing to wear and I actually share his
view on that but we also push back
against it we criticize it we say that
it's not a nice way for women to live
and so I think that's what's being lost
the the critical aspect of Tolerance
where you don't only tolerate people's
views and lifestyles but you also
criticize them that aspect is being lost
and I think that explains a lot of why
we're heading into this politically
correct woke culture in which are not
allowed to criticize anything how much
of that do you think then is directly
related to the media because the way you
just described
comments and he says you know I don't
want women to have to wear the burka but
they should be able to choose that's a
big butt right yeah absolutely this is
the type of thing we see with Trump or
almost anyone on the right all the time
these days there's a headline that
sounds awful and racist and whatever and
then you have to dig into you know page
a chapter you know paragraph 39 where
then you see the qualifying statement
and it's like oh well actually what they
said wasn't that bad I think that's
absolutely right I think the media has
an awful lot to answer for and so does
social media because what you have is a
situation today where anyone who makes a
statement even if it's a reasonable
statement social media and the media
will latch onto it and say you're racist
you're Islamophobic you're a misogynist
even if you are not criticizing
womankind not criticizing all Muslims
not criticizing all black people but
slightly a Muslim woman right exactly
you could be a Muslim woman who thinks
that it's wrong to ask Muslim women to
wear the hijab and you will be branded
Islamophobic for raising those points
this happened in the UK very recently
the Muslim Council of Britain issued a
report on suppose it is llama phobia in
the media and one of his examples was an
Iranian woman who refused to wear the
hijab which is required in Iran by the
way she refused to wear the hijab and
she went on to the BBC and gave an
interview on why she refused to ever hit
up she said it's an oppressive garment
she doesn't like wearing it the Muslim
Council of Britain in the UK held this
interview up as an example of
Islamophobia because they said it wasn't
given the other side and you think
yourself what is the other side the
other side is presumably the theocratic
Iranian Revolutionary Guard a point of
view which is that all women must wear
this garment or else they'll be punished
so you're absolutely right even Muslim
women who raise questions about the way
Muslim women live can be denounced as
Islamophobic can be denounced as
misogynistic and what we're entering
into is a society in which anyone who
raises any questions about cultural
values or social tensions or religious
tensions or anything else can be so
swiftly demonized as racist and phobic
and evil and beyond the pale and even as
a fascist and what that does it
contributes to a sense where you you you
just think there are certain things you
cannot say certain criticisms you cannot
raise and it's very cynically designed I
think to stifle debate about the
problems in society and then it
fascinatingly creates the sort of widest
tent in politics which is worldwide
right now which is the deplorable is
which you're talking a lot about I mean
the example I would give is is from
London I was there about six months ago
and I was on tour with Jordan Peterson
and I went to Harrods which is the
famous department store and something
like seventy percent of the women were
wearing burkas no I'm not look they can
wear whatever they want yeah I take the
liberal position on this of course I
would want them all to live as freely as
they possibly can and all that but what
I would say is I it struck me as odd
yeah I wasn't in Saudi Arabia I wasn't
in Iran but not only that and we having
nothing to do with racism or biggie or
any of those things which is so stupid
that I even have to elucidate that point
to you if there had if I had walked into
Harrods and there had been 70% Amish
women yeah Orthodox Jewish women or
something else that would be alternative
struck me as a little odd yeah this
doesn't feel like whatever London felt
like at one time and if you don't let
people just think about that or talk
about it then you're gonna lead to all
sorts of other crazy things absolutely
right I think Harrods and Selfridges
which is another famous posh shop in
London well the reason let me just want
to think the reason it struck me so hard
is because I am aware that we live in a
weird time related to terror and
everything else and that when you're in
a place that has I mean Harrods is just
packed you're just sort of yeah being
with the mob from room to room yes it's
so packed well if there were groups of
men that you could only see their eyes
yeah you would think it's alarming I
mean that just is it's it sounds
whatever but yeah just is but you know I
think I completely agree I think the
burka is a ridiculous offensive horrible
item of clothing I think the idea that a
woman needs to cover herself from head
to toe so that all you can see is her
eyes is ridiculous it's offensive to
women because
covers them in this black cloth and it's
offensive to men because the whole idea
of it is that these women are so
sexually attractive that men cannot
control their impulses
it's it's in a deeply offensive garment
I also happen to defend women's right to
wear it even though I know that's very
complicated because I know that lots of
women don't exercise free choice right
when they wear this garment but my great
concern is that if you were to say in in
the UK or France or Belgium if you were
to say you are banned from wearing this
garment in public my great concern is
that most of those women would not go
out in public so I think it would
actually limit their freedom in a way
that would be incredibly destructive but
this is the problem we face in
contemporary society where it's it's
become unacceptable to say I'd
absolutely defend your freedom to wear
this ridiculous item of clothing this
backward archaic medieval item of
clothing I defend your freedom to wear
that but I think you're wrong I think
it's it's antisocial I think it is it
makes life more difficult because I
cannot see your face I cannot engage
with you that's where I think political
correctness is really causing problems
where it's no longer acceptable to say
fine
do what you want to do but everyone else
must have the right to criticize what
you do instead we're all supposed to nod
along obediently at all these various
different ways of life even if we know
inside our hearts and minds that it's a
wrong way to live so the expectation of
political correctness that you must
simply obediently accept all lifestyles
I think is a serious problem yeah and
you sort of hit this when you said
anti-social but it also creates this odd
situation where you need to see
someone's yes to read cues you can't
restaurant you can read a lot in the
eyes but there's things about someone's
face and the way they lift their brow
and their moves and all of those things
that allow us to actually connect a
little bit more so then it creates a
secondary level of disconnect that's
right just what someone's where well you
know there was a case in the UK recently
where a woman who wears the niqab wanted
to be able to wear it in a court of law
where she was giving evidence and the
judge said no absolutely unacceptable
because
we need to be able to see the movements
on your face we need we need to see what
you're thinking and in a court of law
that becomes a very pronounced issue
right because you need to know is this
person telling the truth and you judge
people by how they look how their eyes
look how their face looks the facial
expressions they make so I think I would
be in favor of restricting the right of
women to wear the Knik up in a court of
law because you need to be able to see
the face I also would be in favor of
restricting the right of women to wear
the niqab in a school because I think
young children need to be able to see
their teachers face and there's there's
currently big discussion about whether
women should be able to wear the Knik up
in schools in the UK and also in France
I think they shouldn't be allowed to
wear it so there are some areas where I
think the the anti-social element of
that clothing becomes so problematic
that it's acceptable to say you can't
wear it but in the public sphere in
every day walking down the street going
into a shop I would defend freedom the
freedom of women to wear this religious
garment and additional to that I would
defend the right of everyone else to
criticise the fact that these women wear
this garment without being branded
Islamophobic because that phobic
accusation is used so often these days
to brand anyone who simply raises
questions about Islam or transgenderism
or any aspect of contemporary woek
politics anyone who raises any any
criticism of that consent swiftly and
easily be denounced as phobic that it
just becomes incredibly difficult to
have an honest discussion about the
society we live in ok so I think that's
a perfect segue then when it comes to
having an honest discussion about what's
happening in contemporary society you've
been one of the most outspoken brexit
supporters and yet one of the people
that I think is kind of giving it its
intellectual backing so we touch on this
a little bit two years ago roughly so
it's hard to believe this is still being
discussed but for the layman who knows
nothing about brags in what was Bragg's
it about let's just do that in 2 or 3
minutes and then we'll get caught up to
where we're at now yes so in my view
brexit is the most important political
issue in the Western world what happened
is in June 2016 which is so long ago now
17 another world it's it's crazy
seventeen point four million British
people voted to leave the European Union
that's the largest bloc of voters in the
history of the United Kingdom that many
people have never voted for anything so
they voted to we includes me seventeen
point four million people voted to leave
the European Union because the European
Union is an anti-democratic technocratic
bureaucratic a liberal PC institution
which just drains the life out of
democracy and freedom of speech and all
these other key issues so we were right
I believe to oppose the European Union
so we voted against it the the idea was
that we would have this referendum and
whatever we decided would be acted upon
we were told that again and again and
again by David Cameron who was then the
Prime Minister three plus years later
we're still in the European Union we
haven't left and it looks increasingly
like we won't leave so there is now talk
of having a second referendum there is
now talk of simply overriding the vote
there is now talk of Parliament using
its power to deprive the public of the
thing that they voted for and simply
preventing it from happening I think if
that happens it will be it will be an it
will be a really key event in the
history of Britain because what it will
say is that we are no longer really a
democratic nation we are no longer
really a democracy we're no longer a
nation that takes seriously what
ordinary people think so I think a lot
of people across the Western world
really should be keeping a close eye on
breaks it because if breaks it doesn't
happen then the whole nature of
democracy the whole democratic era which
has only existed for a few hundred years
will be called into question because
basically at that point plenty of other
Western leaders who might have some
authoritarian tendencies might go well
yes it doesn't really matter if I win or
lose in election because look what
happened over there
we have delay and delay and delay long
enough until the people either start
flipping or we can make up enough lies
or demonize enough people and then
that's right Congrats the
I'm still in power that's right and I
you know a lot of people used to look to
the United Kingdom for a democratic
example and I was thinking about this
recently it was recently the 30th
anniversary of the Tiananmen Square
massacre when you had hundreds of
thousands of Chinese citizens on the
streets of Beijing and across China
effect demanding democratic rights
demanding the right to freedom demanding
the right to choose their government a
very basic right that people like you
and I take for granted which people in
China don't have and when that massacre
happened 30 years ago in 1989 British
Democrats British liberals British
humanists were talking about it all the
time they were fully in favor of these
people who were struggling for the right
to democracy - for the right to a
democratic say in their lives and in
their communities on the 30th
anniversary however there was a real
sense of silence a lot of British
liberals who would normally have made a
big fuss about the Tiananmen Square
massacre India and the authoritarianism
of the Chinese regime didn't say
anything and I was thinking about this
and I thought ok this makes sense it's
because you are now on the same side as
the Chinese regime and that's not to say
you're going to drive tanks into trogir
Square like the Chinese regime did into
Tiananmen Square and Massacre people or
kill people but you're on the same side
in the sense that you think democracy is
overrated you think people shouldn't
have a free fair say in how their
community or their society is organized
and I thought that silence is so I think
your point is absolutely right there are
so many people around the world who
looked to the UK and to other Western
nations America too for an example of
people having a real say in how their
lives are organized who now will no
longer do that and you have foreign
regimes around the world that will look
at the UK really right and they'll see
that there are members of parliament and
government officials who are hell-bent
on over riding the largest Democratic
vote in the history of our country and
those regimes will say let's do the same
thing so let's just break down a little
bit
this whole thing so so the vote is about
two years ago then you said June of 2016
2016 yeah and then how soon were things
supposed to be in motion
straight away it was supposed to happen
very very quickly and David Cameron who
was Prime Minister and George Osborne
who was the Chancellor of the exec you
he was the in charge of the economy
these two figures who were the leading
figures and he in the United Kingdom
argued that it would happen straightaway
we will listen to you we will act upon
what you say we will do it right off the
bat so everyone was expecting that what
would happen in a matter of weeks or
months and people went to the ballot box
with that view in mind they thought
right this is the this is the first
election in which I'm not simply being
asked to choose between a party who will
run the country we're all asked that in
every single election we take part in
this was a different election this was
an election in which we were being asked
to decide the political makeup of the
nation the constitutional nature of the
nation should we be entangled with the
European Union or should we be
completely independent of it so a lot of
voters I spoke to said that this is the
first time they felt that their vote had
real consequence and would change the
country entirely
so people relish the opportunity voter
turnout went up enormous ly it was 72%
normally it's around 60% so there was a
huge rise in voter turnout especially in
working-class areas and poor areas where
people don't normally vote and people
came out in their millions and said
let's leave the European Union and they
expected it would happen very quickly
more than three years later it's thought
so what happened that caused the pause
the delay and now the possible reversal
of this day well the the key issue is
that the political class doesn't want to
leave the European Union I mean this is
the great tension in the United Kingdom
at the moment and I think is actually
reflected in American politics to a
certain extent to and across Europe in
fact as well in the UK a majority of
votes
want to leave the European Union but a
majority of the political cast doesn't
and that's the key tension say for
example 52% of people voted to leave the
European Union that's a majority
seventeen and a half million but in the
political class 70% of members of
parliament voted to stay in the European
Union with the Labour Party which is our
version of the Democrat Party it was 95
percent 95 percent of Labour MPs voted
to stay in the European Union I mean
that is how utterly disconnected the
supposedly left-wing party is from
public sentiment I mean it is simply
extraordinary that 95 percent of Labour
MPs as against just 48 percent of the
public voted to stay in the European
Union so we have this difficult
historically unprecedented situation
where the people want one thing and the
political class want another and and the
great unfortunate thing is that the
political class is getting its way so
okay so I think the average person
listening to this at least from an
American lens would go well wait a
minute we have elections and no matter
what the result is incumbents get booted
and they gotta go we bring in this guy
this whole thing happens they keep
telling us that trumps never gonna leave
office but in many ways and you will
Democrats yeah except this is all I got
ok all that so what actually is
happening I mean are they literally just
that that percentage that 70% they're
just saying we're just not going to put
the processes in motion that would allow
for we're just so they're they're not
denying that they're denying the will of
the people I guess that's what I'm
asking right or are they or they're
saying you're true you were tricked
right doesn't yes it's a lot that you
were tricked into voting for this and
we're doing what's better for you that's
the key thing so that so they would
never openly say we hate the will of the
people you think you're all idiots and
we're just going to ignore you yeah a
little bit right so they they had they
put a bit of spin on it they put it
they'd put a kind of PC gloss on the
fact that they are actually undermining
the democratic process so what they say
is we were tricked we will lie to we're
a bunch of idiots
they crazy we're
races with xenophobic the phrase they
uses low information you are which is a
fancy phrase for you know stupid but
that's what they say you're low
information you didn't have all the
information you didn't understand the
consequences of leaving the European
Union you you know you're not educated
enough you're not switched on enough you
know even people like Richard Dawkins
have been saying it was wrong and stupid
to entrust such a big political decision
to ordinary people because they think we
are inferior to their history know that
it's me but it's such an important
moment because I think it really sums up
where politics is going where
politically correct politics is going
where woke politics is going because
what it's doing is creating this almost
this neo aristocracy where you have this
layer of people who think they know
better than us they know how you should
speak in Asia how you should behave they
know how you should think and they are
superior to us that they are educated
they went to the right universities they
have the right attitudes and then down
here there are the kind of the throng
the masses the idiots who don't speak in
the right way who don't have the right
attitudes who aren't sufficiently PC who
aren't sufficiently woke and they can be
bossed around they can be ignored they
can be told what to do and tell what to
think so I think actually that the war
against brexit which is fundamentally a
war against democracy actually speaks to
the political culture of the Western
world more broadly where you have this
the creation of this two-tier political
system where at the top you have these
switched-on elites who think they know
better than the rest of us and they have
no concern at all about bossing us
around and censoring us and demonizing
us and telling us we're stupid and
blocking the things that we vote for so
I think at the heart of brexit what we
can see is it is the elites war against
supposedly deplorable people
[Music]